[музика]
в Україні мешкає Понад мільйон мусульман
це одна з найбільших релігійних громад і
подекуди значно ліберальніша ніж Можна
було б очікувати
Моє ім'я Мітя Я представник команди
трекс East сьогодні Я зустрічаюся з
аміною Вона живе у Києві а Міна
мусульманнка та модна блогерка вона
відкрито говорить про свою віру в неї
Понад 120 000 підписників у tiktok
виховувалась мусульманській сім'ї От і
мене наче оточував завжди іслам я
свідомо стала мусульманкою Ось і
вирішила вирішила одягти хустку і ось це
було мені здається років 13 в Києві і в
Україні дуже багато як і
арабів кримських татар українців які
прийняли іслам з віком Та ну різних
національностей які і приїхали і
народились тут і живуть тут от і ходять
мечеть чи можливо поєднати релігію
tiktok та моду в Україні вочевидь можна
Аміна першому сунманська дівчина яка
стала модною блогеркою в Україні не
ніколи не було і я можу сказати Як
представляю
таку мусульманську блогерську общину по
суті якої ще нема мода грає дуже велику
роль в моєму житті тому що завдяки моді
завдяки своєму блогу якраз таки одна з
моїх цілей мого блога це показувати
людям взагалі хто така сучасна
мусульманка тобто в сучасно мусульманка
- це про розум це про стиль це про
харизму це про багатогранність тобто
знаєш І якось розвіювати ось ці
стереотипи які є у багатьох людях
Київська мечеть духовного управління
мусульман України умма вважається
ліберальною Та є популярним місцем
зустрічей послідовників Ісламу зокрема і
для аміни та її друзів війна холод та
перебої з електрикою останнім часом
майже єдині теми їхніх розмов
автор тому що десь на хвилини три світло
пропало але потім воно з'явилось і тут є
і тепло і де зарядитись є І от wi-fi це
класно але квартирах в
домівлях то з цим дуже проблематично
може може бути відсутність світла десь
не знаю 1 12 тобто наприклад я Особисто
я ми з сім'єю сиділи без світла без
опалення ну години
не знаю доби дві десь доби дві
Аміна та її друзі у Києві намагаються за
можливості витіснити війну зі свого
побуту
[музика]
їм хочеться жити нормальним життям як
колись до війни
з цими подругами з якими я спілкуюся в
мечеті ми познайомились в школі тому що
у нас якби при мечеті є школа можливість
помолитися вона ну є тільки в
мусульманській гімназіях але звісно і в
звичайних якихось школах ти можеш просто
на перерві відійти в якісь там пустий
кабінет помолитись ну тобто звісно але
знаєш коли ти молишся в реальній такої
мечеті з своїми друзями мусульманами так
з браттям і сестрами по Вірі то Ну це
набагато цінніше розумієш
але перебої зі струмом та вибухи не
дають а мініспокою
майже щоденно вона стикається з
наслідками війни
[музика]
мені страшно я не знаю що думати про
свої залишатись тут чи кудись їхати чи
ну ці ціле життя Воно під питанням
[музика]
Аміна прямує до мечеті вона домовилася з
імамом поговорити про війну
як завжди тут відбувається щотижнева
п'ятнична молитва
аміну цікавить чому так багато
українських мусульман також йдуть на
війну
якщо ми говоримо про мусульман громадян
України то це зрозуміло це напад на них
так само як і напад на всіх інших Вони
захищають свою рідну домівку захищають
свої землі захищають своїх близьких свою
сім'ю це їхній обов'язок борг релігійний
зокрема як і цивільний якщо ми навіть
говоритимемо про мусульман які не є
громадянами України ті ж наприклад
чеченські добровольці Чому вони прийшли
для них Росія цей спільний ворог це
країна загарбник Росія колись захопила
їхній рідний дім і ось протягом усіх цих
часів віків продовжується пригнічення
утиск несправедливість щодо їхніх
народів Росія - це прямий спадкоємець
Радянського Союзу Радянський Союз
знищував релігію саме в істинному
значенні цього слова він знищував усіх
незалежних справжніх духовних осіб
богословів учених які мусульманських так
і християнських
саид из могилов колишній муфті
мусульманської громади ума в Україні
воює за Україну з перших днів після
вторгнення у березні 2022 року він склав
повноваження духовного лідера
українських мусульман та став Медиком
відтоді Саїд рятує життя на передовій
Він знає що мусульмани в Україні також
переживають складні часи через агресію
Росії
[музика]
сьогодні до нас у полон потрапила
Трофейна сумка
найбільша кількість мусульман
окупації Крима та Донбасу після окупації
Росією Крима та Донбасу у 2014 році
2/третини мусульман України залишилась
на тимчасово окупованих територіях були
великі потоки переселенців на вільні
території України декілька десятків
тисяч російська влада проводить певні з
одного боку репресивні заходи проти
мусульман України а з іншого боку
асимілятивні заходи
що стосується репресивних заходів Вони
почали ще з 2014 року коли мусульман
переважно у Криму масова саджали заграти
чеченський автократ Рамзан Кадиров
оголосив за його словами священну війну
Україні та відправляє у бій свої
мусульманські загони слово Джихад
змінило світ фанатики чинять злочини в
ім'я релігії
[музика]
але й українські мусульмани тепер
говорять про священну війну для них
йдеться про інше про захист своєї
батьківщини
[оплески]
Україна знаходяться на війні мусульмани
України
які захищають Україну тут на війні вони
фактично знаходяться на джихаді Джихад з
точки зору сламу це захист
себе своєї родини своїх дітей своєї
країни
від агресора
а міні - це не додає спокою число
українських мусульман які опираються
російській агресії зростатиме і надалі
Привіт моє ім'я Юлія боксleр я
журналістка подкасттерка та режисерка
я режисерка редакторка та журналістка
народилася в 1997 році в Маріуполі
особливо останнім часом Коли багато з
цих регіонів потерпають від війни та
кризи
релігія набула дуже специфічною ролі
причому дуже політизованої
моє дитинство в Німеччині пройшло під
впливом російської православної церкви і
для мене відвідування цієї церкви було
не завжди добровільним рішенням Ось чому
я у 13 років вирішила Вийти з цієї
громади Сьогодні я розумію чому тоді
будучи дитиною я інтуїтивно вирішила
більше не бути частиною російської
православної церкви бо зараз на
богослужіннях унія агітують за війну із
вірою це не має нічого спільного
усім Привіт моє ім'я Ігор садєв Колись я
був головним редактором Московського
інтернет-видання the village проте тепер
За моїм вікном більше не Москва і коли
друзі просять показати визначні пам'ятки
російської столиці доводиться робити ось
так
червоною площею чи кремлем нікого не
здивуєш Але є одна визначна пам'ятка
дуже актуальна цього сезону це храм
збройних сил Росії його збудували
неподалік Москви два роки тому Але після
початку війни з Україною він став свого
роду зловісним символом того що в домі
Бога можна не лише молитися за мир а й
агітувати за війну
це відео з офіційного каналу
Міністерства оборони Росії роздивимося
храм детальніше зазвичай сухі цифри
найнудніша частина екскурсії але тільки
не тут ось центральний купол храму його
діаметр 22 м та 43 см цифра невипадкова
у 22 годині 43 хвилині було підписано
Акт про капітуляцію Німеччини у Другій
світовій війні висота храму 96 м у цій
цифрі зашифровано рік народження Князя
Володимира який хрестив Русь заходимо
всередину обережно сходинки на ґнку
відлиті з трофейних німецьких Танків і
гармат
всередині храм розділений на чотири
приділи кожен присвячений святим
покровителям різних видів військ з
авіацію наприклад відповідає пророк Ілля
а за ракети зокрема з ядерними
боєголовками наглядає свята Варвара так
знає від таких поєднань стає не по собі
і це почуття взагалі постійно
супроводжує коли дивишся на цей храм
зверніть увагу це Ісус із мечем проте
головна окраса храму мозаїки з
батальними сценами з історії Ось
червоноармійці та палаючи рейстаг А це
здається Сталінградська битва а тут
взагалі щось сучасне у руках у солдатів
автомати Калашнікова а з останнього
переліку так зване Воз'єднання Криму
Криму присвячена й окрема мозаїка вся
Справа в тому що художники вирішили
зобразити на ній Володимира Путіна і
навіть зібрали його обличчя але в
останній момент замінили на ікону що теж
цілком символічно
релігія в Росії давно стала державною
справою А Російська православна церква
фактично таким же відомством як
Міністерство Внутрішніх чи зовнішніх
справ не дивно що храм російської армії
освятив особисто Патріарх Кирило і він
же став його настоятелем церква
підтримує війну від самого початку а
патріарх виступає відверто войовничо
часто переходячи з мови проповіді на
штампи телевізійної пропаганди навесні
він довго пояснював Чому війна з
Україною необхідна повторюючи путінські
тези про єдиний братні народ та
підступний захід щоправда патріарх додав
до цього ще дещо від себе мовляв
зовнішній ворог нав'язано Донбасі свої
цінності
сьогодні є такий тест на лояльність цієї
влади
тест дуже простий і водночас жахливий
це гей-парад з цим злом Росії бореться
закидаючи бомбами Київ та інші
українські міста далі у храмі російської
армії навіть освятили вітраж зібраний зі
скляних уламків із зруйнованого
Маріуполя А у вересні коли Путін
оголосив мобілізацію військових патріарх
оголосив так звану духовну мобілізацію і
гарантував усім загиблим відпущення
гріхів ця жертва змиває усіх гріхи які
людина здійснила нещодавно патріарх
дійшов до останнього аргументу світ
поринає в хаос і темряву якщо Росія не
переможе то з'явиться
дехто хто претендуватиме на глобальну
владу із ім'ям якого буде пов'язаний
кінець світу
тепер антихриста наповно використовує
російська пропаганда один чиновник
ізради безпеки Росії заявив що Україна
перетворилася на величезну секту яка
поклоняється сатані а колишній президент
Дмитро Медведєв сказав прямо мета Росії
в Україні зупинити верховного володаря
пекла яке б ім'я він не використовував
Сатана Люцифер чи ібліс так-так
російська армія воює проти сатани такого
старозавітного сюжету навіть стіни цього
Храму певно не бачили
[музика]
Уявіть що ви одягли червоний костюм і
стали поруч із білим парканом А за
кілька годин вас за це заарештували
такою є реальністю Білорусії поєднання
червоного з білим - Це кольори
національного прапора Білорусі
заборонені режимом Лукашенка у таких
умовах зараз живуть художники та Взагалі
всі люди в цій країні у Варшаві Мені
вдалося зустрітися з однією білоруською
художницею Машею Мороз вона вже 15 років
займається дослідженням та збереженням
традиційної білоруської культури тепер і
ви можете дізнатися який вдається
працювати за таких умов Меня зовут Маша
Мороз я Моє ім'я Маша Мороз я художниця
етнографка Та дизайнерка я народилася у
Білорусі у Бресті Віра є важливою
частиною моїх досліджень архаїчної
культури білорусів
Зараз я перебуваю у Варшаві Я приїхала
сюди побачитися зі своїми друзями бо
багато хто з них вимушено покинув
Білорусь
а також тут у мене заплановано кілька
подій пов'язаних з моєю художньою
практикою
[музика]
на протяжении протягом останніх 15 років
Я вивчаю полісся це особливий регіон у
Білорусі який займає південь брестську
та гомельську області а також невелику
частину Мінської області
небольшую часть Минской области это
удивитель це дивовижні місця бо саме на
Поліссі збереглася архаїчна культура
сохранилась збереглося багато традицій
обрядів які більше ніде у світі зустріти
неможливомоєліченько я не перечила
[музика]
Олесь я в первую очередь насамперед
полісся - це вода це болота це
найдавніші ліси Це земля якої практично
не торкнулася глобалізація
до этого и завдяки відокремленості від
решти світу збереглася не тільки
унікальна природа але також і дуже
багато етнографічна спадщина и очень
богатая этнографическое Наследие полісся
- це місце магічних пошуків перетину
безлічі вірувань
на полезе есть одно удивительно на
Поліссі є одне дивовижне місце де люди
досі поклоняються деревам і приїжджають
за зцілення вони моляться і прив'язують
до дерев стрічки тим самим здійснюючи
такий енергетичний обмін це місце
славиться тим що тут відбувається багато
чудес багато зцілення в ней можно
проследить тут можна простежити глибокий
зв'язок людини з природою
От христианства і це щось далеке від
християнства Ця історія більше про
язичництво шаманізм і Звісно це
унікально уникально
[музика]
за последних 2 года Минск очень за
останні два роки Мінськ дуже сильно
змінився дуже багато людей покинули не
лише місто а й країну і звичайно це дуже
позначається на енергетиці
в целом учитывая загалом враховуючи які
події щодня відбуваються в Білорусі і в
сусідніх країнах не так багато є
приводів для оптимізму тут дуже тяжке
повітря звісно енергія мертва Тобто це
пов'язано з тим що дуже багато закрилося
різних інституцій закладів галерей та
ініціатив
все Це дуже змінило життя
[музика]
Белорусская церковь подчиняется
білоруська церква підпорядковується
російській православній церкві є певний
дискурс якого має дотримуватись
служителі церкви і було помітно що треба
дотримуватись певних поглядів офіційної
влади
[музика]
находясь в этом перебуваючи у цьому
затишному моєму улюбленому храмі хотів
би звернутися не лише до наших білорусів
а й передусім до наших сусідів давайте
берегти мир давайте бере
по сегодняшний день нині у житті
білорусі в релігія відіграє досить
важливу роль тобто білоруси - це віруюча
нація відсоток атеїстів на мою думку
досить невисокий Я думаю достаточно
невысокий
[музика]
Привіт Привіт Машо вітаю я Маша я Маша
привет Адам Дуже приємно Мені теж
Проходьте будь ласка заходи
те фільмую придорожні хрести Полісся
при въезде при в'їзді в село на виїзді
та в центрі села ставлять хрести для
того щоб людина будь-якої миті могла
звернутися до вищих сил хрести повинні
захищати село від лиха епідемії нещасних
випадків ця давня традиція досі жива
[музика]
це така суміш християнства та язичництва
і цікавилися у людей чому вони це
роблять
я разговарива я спілкуюся зараз з людьми
у селах Я запитую за якими принципами
вони декорують хрести чому обирають такі
образи
адже в Білорусі завжди було змішування
культур Вона завжди знаходилася між
різними течіями хоча це центр Європи
Белорусская культура достаточно уязвима
білоруська культура досить вразлива
протягом останніх століть Білорусь та
білоруська культура перебувають у
перманентному опорі та режимі виживання
під впливом постійної русифікації
справді потрібно докладати зусиль для
того щоб наша ідентичність не була
розмита щоб збереглася пам'ять білорусів
пам'ять белорусов
забобони безумовно дуже поширені в тих
країнах з яких ми походимо
коли моя тітка приїжджала в гості то
вона з мамою зазвичай спілкувалася з
домовиком вони справді радилися з ним
тобто ставили серйозні запитання про те
що на них чекає в житті
коли хтось помирає Що ви робите вам не
можна шуміти не можна голосно розмовляти
Потрібно відкрити вікно та завісити
чимось дзеркала
у мене вдома Все було досить атеїстично
єдине що хоч якось збереглося це
траволікування яке опанувала моя мама
бабуся і я на жаль теж знаюся на цьому
подобається це мені чи ні це перейшло й
до мене так У цьому є щось чаклунське
Звичайно це такий ярлик і в ньому є щось
жіноче цим займаються переважно жінки і
так це часто трапляється
Ти маєш рацію травознавство знову
вважається чимось майже загальновизнаним
нормальним Думаю сьогодні ставлення до
нього переосмислюється і в мистецтві
адже ці ритуальні чаклунські практики
мають багато спільного з перформансом
[музика]
Я думаю що ми маємо повернути фігуру
ромської відьми Яка й досі
стигматизована в нашій уяві у цьому
немає нічого ганебного це не стереотип і
не екзотика А це справжня професія якою
наші жінки займалися протягом століть і
надзвичайно цікаво що ця професія все ще
існує жінки практикують її сьогодні
[музика]
моє ім'я міхаела дреган і я людина
мистецтва займаюся кількома видами
творчості Я родом із бухареста що в
Румунії але працювала у багатьох
європейських містах сьогодні ввечері я
виступаю зі своєю п'єсою травматичний
перегин йдеться про сексуальне
самовизначення та уподобання але в
основному про психічні травми
[музика]
у багатьох моїх проектах Я говорю про
міжпоколінські травми йдеться про те що
травми успадковуються через нашу ДНК
протягом кількох поколінь
[музика]
у травмах та жорстокому поводженні немає
нічого сексуального абсолютно нічого
якось я подивилася значення цього слова
у словнику і Там вказано травма іменник
жіночого роду
[музика]
ідентифікація з образом відьми як така є
політичним феміністським актом тому що
відьма має владу над своєю долею та
долею ромського народу
Вона може проклинати фашистських
політиків які зневажають ромів і вона
може допомогти зцілити наші спадкові
травми Вона жінка з величезною силою яка
врятує нас
[музика]
Нещодавно я зняла кілька фільмів під
назвою майбутнє - це безпечне місце
заховане в моїх косах
вони присвячені чаклунству ромів і цій
владі яку ромські відьми мають у нашому
суспільстві
Community
і
joviel
люди часто запитують мене чи вірю Я в
силу віддьм мені чесно кажучи байдуже чи
є в них така Влада насправді думаю що
всі ми маємо силу всередині себе у
кожному нашому слові є сила Я також
вважаю що багато людей сприймають
чаклунство якщо що призначене для
неосвічених нераціональних людей і це
звичайно євроцентричні Погляд який цінує
раціональність та науковість але
чаклунство завжди було чимось Що
належало корінним народам
[музика]
насправді працює Тому що тут у Румунії
так багато білих чоловіків які нажахані
магією моїх відео може навести безліч
прикладів коли політики ухвалювали
закони проти ромського народу та відьо
потім відьми з'являлися на телебаченні
та погрожували накласти на них Прокляття
і одразу ж ці політики скасовували свої
закони
[музика]
у ромській громаді ми зростаємо в
атмосфері заклинань та чаклунства у селі
де я виросла люди мали глибинний зв'язок
із цим всім
Мої дітки наприклад ворожили на картах
Таро
ворожили на кавовій гущі Я навіть
пам'ятаю як моя мати вимовляла любовні
заклинання
Техно відьми - Це ще один мій проект
царепальбом який Я випустила разом із
Ніко G ідеться про відьму з майбутнього
яка контролює технології тому вона й
техновідьма
багато текстів наших пісень містять
заклинання Прокляття чи рецепти різного
зілля
[музика]
наша мета охопити якомога більшу
аудиторію і Я дуже сподіваюся що наші
пісні зможуть подарувати молодим ромам
більше впевненості в собі
[музика]
Не думаю що я можу ідентифікувати себе з
якоюсь релігією
чаклунство просто набагато веселіше та
креативніше
Загалом я часто критикую релігії за
велику кількість поганого що вони
принесли людям
і під цим я маю на увазі цілком
конкретні погані речі
Наприклад колоніалізм який був би
немислимий без християнства або безліч
інших злочинів тому я б сказала що вірю
у права людини це моя релігія
кому мапа
[музика]
[оплески]